catchers I would say probably the advantage goes
to the pelicil early in the season the power play
has to be perfect the penalty kill we're together
no Rolling Puck in on goaltender Ray Melky settles
it down he had trouble initially reaching
for it they'll be working on that quite a bit
before the regular season starts power play
winding down in tight a chance and a goal Barrett
Hayden took the feed from Keller at the goal line
spun and shot and beat Calvin for the game's first
goal well five on five it was all Kings and then
the first power play for the coyotes and they
really have taken control you talk about execution
the pass is the movement first thing you have to
do is win a Face-Off you spread out you go to your
spots but then very quickly hate will get himself
a little room he took one big stride from the goal
line below out in front but then the quick hands
I mentioned earlier the previous save by Talbot he
was a good position didn't have to move that time
Hayden upgraded the goaltender pulls it drags it
and very quickly hoists it Top Shelf looks to make
a play but the pass is broken up here is carcone
off on the right wing Gorge McBain a give and go
with a shot McBain to save loose Buck cleared
away coyotes are on it again right-wing boards
a chance wide carconi [Applause] Anderson Dolan
swats at it can clear held in Cooley down to the
right circle from where he scored yesterday Julie
up high kerfoot spinning holding on [Applause]
her Cooley lost the puck but
they're to pick roughing in behind
you can see the reason he probably went wide
because they milk got a pretty good angle on
the play best chances at the ends expenses out
there with the piala up high fielo feeds it right
side gets it back from Cafe to Cafe one he scores
that didn't take very long [Applause] fiala goes
to the middle options right options left decides
I'm going the same place I went the first time
40 plus last year for Cafe the release and
the short side to placement as important
right there because you see van Loca
he came across I mean he was there but
for the young kids but they're at that stage now
where they're ready to take the next step talk
about playoffs Bill told us the other day maybe
not playoffs but at the same time not counting it
out yeah they are trending in the right direction
with all the young Talent shots [Applause] from
the right point I don't think it was tipped Jacob
moberara against the Kings their first lead today
and of course former hour he's in a he's in
a fight for his job low Corner watches low
now there's traffic there I don't think it
was touch Nick as you mentioned but that
moving traffic we saw in game one yesterday
High backswing yeah goes all the way through
almost goes seven hole right there underneath
the arm of the goaltender but you can see how
they melka would have a tough time finding that
puck better shot handled by her Riddick [Applause]
and the Kings take over with Cali of his lead
pass tipped down the ice picked up fiala fiala
in front of Paris deflection on goal it's loose
and covered for a whistle brinestrom making sure
he gets to the Lane get your legs in front of a
stick and that's exactly what he does to block it
Jersey will get it in deep the net empty to our
left can pay with it a look at the Anthony net
his shot and he scores from his half of Center
Ice Adrian kempe with 39.5 seconds left season
he has no other option and the odds nowadays the
analytics say take your chance up high kerfoot
feeds right side draconia shot and they score on
the tip-in might have been McBain off to the right
of Riddick [Music] we'll get a great look at it
here because off to the side this is a hard play
carcone says I'm getting it to the front something
just take it take a chance of it hitting something
does it get all the way through we're not sure
on two seconds one and that will do it with
three third period goals the Kings defeat Arizona
three to two here in the second game of the global
series weekend here in Australia the coyotes
took game number one by a score of five to three
so Todd McClellan had seven again uh we
will have a shootout despite the fact
the Kings won in regulation to start
brunch from his shot denied by they
malka machelli one of the top scoring
rookies last year a shot and a bad save
[Music] piala seeking scores
edgework the ability to create the deception then
use the edges of your skates to change directions
no one does it as well as fiala look at this
inside edges both way the left skate bites in the
goaltender moving across and if you're Velma oh
yeah that change of direction is just too fast too
deceptive good hands finishes it off Logan Cooley
had that great goal yesterday and check done the
play by The Stick of Riddick that'll do it for the
shootout fiala the only goal we had eight Shooters
in the exhibition shootout as the two teams come
off the bench and the NHL 2023 Global series comes
to an end here in Melbourne Australia coyotes win
yesterday the Kings win here today Kevin fiala
showing off the skill three stars being announced
right here after the game we saw this yesterday
Adrian kempe will get the second star of the game
two goals the last one into the empty net [Music]
first star [Applause] who else
there you go taking the ripping from his
teammates here now on a fixed file and
you may think that this is The Logical choice
but he played well oh no he preserves it yeah
foreign the coyotes salute the crowd here
the king salute the crowd Nick it has been
fantastic they call Melbourne the sporting capital
of Australia whether it's tennis rugby Australian
Rules Football Grand Prix soccer growing golf Aki
has now made its imprint on Melbourne Australia